[Music]
everyone's face was looking at me I saw
fear take hold of everyone in that
theater tell me what the mood is like
for you tonight well I mean there's a
little bit of trepidation if only
because I think people's expectations of
what this film are are a little heavy
but ultimately really the story is about
friendship and and and people
collectively coming together to help
each other through a horrible event and
I think when people see the film they're
able to understand that it's really more
of an uplifting film than it is a you
know a downer these people are your
friends and they told me actually that
they advised you not to do this they did
because that's what friends do but as a
friend I wasn't about to let them go
through this kind of thing alone which i
think is the sentiment that a lot of
other people share a little bit of a
lighter note the movie Orange County
turns 15 this year excuse me sorry Sean
have you seen my piss my parole officer
called he wants that piss cuz ma'am I
know I got it around here lanceton
company Jack's here tonight right yeah I
heard yeah what does that movie means
you today oh I mean that to me is I'm
really proud of that movie I'm really
proud of the people I made it with you
know I had a really fun time and the
fact that you know anybody is talking
about something you did 15 years ago
that's very special so it's not lost on
me you we're all over the internet this
week after getting together with busy on
the Kelly Ripa show
did the internet make a bigger deal out
of that then they should have well the
internet tends to make a big deal about
whenever exes see each other
never mind when exes have to interview
each other or be interviewed by each
other so ya know that was actually a lot
of fun and you know I love busy and
been friends for a very long time now
and I'm just so lucky to be able to to
look over her and just see an amazing
individual who I admire a great deal and
and you know and that goes for when
we're on live with Kelly but it also
goes for when we're dropping our kids
off in school